Logan Paul is refunding people he
scammed if they promis to stop suing him
for the vastly larger amount he may owe
them and honestly I'm conflicted because
on the one hand victims getting money is
always great and I'm proud that our
investigation led to some real world
consequences but I can't pretend that
things are fixed or fine for people who
entrusted me with their story when
that's just not true so here's the real
more complicated story in three parts
the refund offer the zoo tokens the
lawsuit stting with the most important
part and if you get one thing from the
story this should be it these are the
estimated damages in crypto Zoo 18.5
million which comes from a combination
of zcoin and nft sales and then this
much smaller percentage of that pie is
what Logan is actually offering to
refund on the condition though that all
of the people who spent the last year
suing him for the larger damages Dro
their case so that's a refund of only
12% to drop 100% of the the case that as
far as I can tell Logan may be losing
put in that light then this refund
starts to look less like a goodfaith
attempt to make things right and more
like a cynical bargaining chip to avoid
getting in even more trouble and a
careful look at these refunds conditions
show that Logan is even less serious of
a person you may give him credit for
Logan is offering only a one-month claim
window for this refund given a year
after waiting and hidden in this wall of
text is the most shock part which is
that he's not releasing the crypto zoo
game at all which I know we all kind of
knew that but is actually insane because
that's the thing to be clear he sold
millions of dollars of nfts for and tens
of millions of dollars of in-game crypto
Zoo tokens for I knew he wasn't going to
make it right we all get that but I
watched for three years as Logan's fans
and that's what these investors were
they were fans of Logan Paul they spent
three years begging this guy to make
this game and the entire time the entire
time he told them he was working on it
and I thought even at my most
pessimistic that Logan would at least
crap out some Abomination that he
described as a game that limped past our
lowest Collective expectations but I was
wrong I mean I wasn't wrong the first
time he said I was wrong when he said he
was going to still finish the game I was
wrong that he was going to do it at all
but even after 12 months of work you've
still managed to overlook one crucial
piece of information see even though
I've said it's coming so many times
you've assumed that crypto zo isn't
being made who are you to decide when
the development timeline ends trust me
crypto zoo is coming I will make damn
sure of it oops so much for making damn
sure of it because there's no game this
is what makes this such a massive con
this guy sold millions in nfts tens of
millions of zoo tokens and he's not even
going to release the thing he promised
this whole time this is why it's such a
slap in the face these investors spent 3
years waiting for a game not only that
two years waiting for an update which he
never gave and then a year suing him and
after all of that all he offers is a 12%
refund no game 30 days to accept so look
Logan's already taking heat for making
good on a promise that he made a year
late but that's not even true he's not
making good on this promise because it's
not the same promise last year what he
promised was no strings attached buyback
and you get a game
this year it's please drop your lawsuit
and you don't get a game which is
incredible to me that there are
influencers out there like KSI parading
this around like a win for Logan Paul
like he's some sort of hero for offering
a year late half-baked settlement offer
KSI says what will the haters say now I
don't know how about where's the game
where's the art where's the millions
invested where's the motivation for this
tweet oh wait KSI is a co-founder with
Logan and Prime so of course that makes
KSI Logan's new biggest fan but seeing
as how Logan treats his biggest fans
don't say I didn't warn you so that's
part one the refund now part two is the
zoo tokens remember there were two parts
to crypto zoo the zoo tokens and egg
nfts now the tokens were the vast amount
of Damages that were actually caused
while the nft sales were much lower
Logan conveniently wants to refund this
much smaller part of his game the nfts
while pretending that these Zoo tokens
were never a real part they were just
gambling now this was sort of less bad
when the game was still going to come
out because you know it made some sense
maybe you'd still have these tokens but
now it makes no sense at all from
Logan's statement this buyback is a way
for me to make whole those who intended
to play crypto Zoo the buyback is not
intended to compensate those who gambled
on the crypto market and lost so he's
describing people who bought his in-game
currency as gamblers but that's
confusing because the whole point of
these Zoo tokens was to buy the egg nfts
and play the game that's literally how
it worked according to him so instead he
calls people gamblers despite also
saying quote Zoo token was created to
support the crypto zoo game and its
players it was quote not intended to be
an investment vehicle so how can he say
that then turn around and say people who
bought this were gambling if it's not an
investment how can you refund people who
intended to play crypto Zoo if you don't
refund people who bought the token that
was quote created to support the crypto
Zoo game you can't it makes no sense and
this is why I say this isn't even close
to a full refund and now that he's
abandoning the game well we actually
have his millions of dollars of in-game
currency Logan sold that he won't pay
back which brings us to the final part
of this story the third part the lawsuit
after telling all his fans that they
were gamblers who lost Logan has one
final surprise he says quote I have
filed a lawsuit in federal court in
Texas to hold these Bad actors
accountable people who ruin crypto Zoo
but what what Logan doesn't tell you is
that Texas lawsuit is something he's
being sued in already he's a defendant
in the lawsuit that he links in his
tweet he's just cross suing his Cod
defendant like he's already being sued
and he's just resuing the same guys who
are already being sued and who are these
secret Bad actors Logan's going to hold
accountable anyways turns out it's his
employees he hired Eddie ianz and crypto
King which all of us already knew
because I investigated the story a year
ago but imagine my surprise when Logan
Paul tries to rewrite my investigation
to pretend he did all the work himself
and uncovered the real scam of cryptozoo
while simultaneously trying to erase his
part in it he says and I find this very
funny because I spent a year on that
story quote this lawsuit is the result
of an exhaustive investigation that
included the review of the entirety of
conversations you'd be forgiven to think
he was quoting my investigation he's not
he copied it and tried to rewrite it to
make himself look good in this lawsuit
he says things like hey guys turns out
Eddie ibanez's entire backstory was a
fabrication including the MIT NFL story
can you believe it it's like yeah we
know and then he goes yeah well you
won't believe what I discovered crypto
King secretly sold
tokens yeah we know Logan just
shamelessly rips off my work claim for
claim without sighting me I mean he says
things like Mr Green bomb would later
admit that he made millions of dollars
to his surreptitious sales of zoo tokens
but where did Logan find that admission
was it perhaps when he investigated my
video time and time again this lawsuit
copies my work but is embarrassed to
cite it so they even have to say things
like based on public reports what public
report Mr ianz made approximately $1.7
million from selling Zoot tokens I could
swear I've heard that before and for my
calculations he made about $1.7 million
now look I don't usually mind people
using my work but it's kind of a little
strange that Logan is simultaneously
trying to discredit my work saying this
lawsuit is not based on Snippets of
conversation taken out of context a
snipe at my investigation while then
stealth quoting it to pretend that they
did any real leg work and look if you
found that Shameless that he tries to
steal my work and pass it off as his own
investigation this part gets even worse
because Logan's story this whole time
has been that it's all other people's
fault you know it's just bad actors
everyone but him was bad he was always
well-intentioned but his timeline
contradicts him according to his
investigation which is actually my
investigation in August and October of
2021 he learns that Jake green bomb and
Eddie ianz are bad news and he kicks
them out of his team so what does he do
after that he's gotten rid of the Bad
actors can't blame them anymore right
right does he make cryptozoo no for a
full year before I made my video Logan
Paul had full control over his project
he admits it in his own lawsuit and he
did nothing he said nothing so how does
he avoid accountability now well enter
The Whipping Boy Jeff that's right
manager Jeff is making one last
appearance Logan blames Jeff for
screwing up September 2021 through 2022
but you know what he doesn't mention
what he'll never mention the real reason
the project didn't get back on track is
not because of Eddie not because of
crypto King but because Logan's own team
stopped paying developers who were
working on rebuilding the game so those
people stopped working on kryptoo and
that's when I found it the game was dead
it had been dead for months and that's
when I made a big stink out of it
meaning it was 100% within Logan's power
to save this game I'm not saying nobody
else did bad things but Logan ultimately
had over a year to launch it to make
things right and he didn't
for financial reasons not because
someone backstabbed him he just didn't
want to spend the money it would take to
make things right and you know what that
is still true now it is still 100%
within Logan Paul's power as a near
billionaire with prime to make things
right fully right with his fans who he
scammed and if he did gave a full refund
we would all celebrate me foremost but
will he or will he try to dodge
responsibility cheap out rip his fans
off and void accountability I think it's
the latter so those are the three main
points you're all caught up to recap
part one refunds they're being used as a
bargaining chip to drop a lawsuit and so
he never has to produce this game which
has been promised for 3 years and he
sold tens of millions of dollars for
part two is the zoo tokens he's
pretending they're not for a game that
they definitely were for to avoid
refunding people when in fact he admits
they were created to support the game
part three is the lawsuit where he stole
my investigation tried to pass it off as
his own but just cuts out the part where
he did everything wrong and leaves out
the entire year where he was solely in
charge of the project No Bad actors he
could have fixed everything but he
didn't because he he he's cheap and
doesn't want to pay anybody anyway I
hope that catches you up with what's
been going on and I hope we as a
community can have the nuance and
complexity to hold in Our Minds two
things at the same time as true one it's
always good if victims get any money
back and we should celebrate that
however number two is that doesn't mean
we can't fight for 100% of what they
deserve and Logan Paul is not a hero for
doing this or making things right he's a
Serial scammer who's offering a minority
refund as a last Stitch effort to save
his wallet and his
[Music]
reputation